um first of all very happy to be here
we're all the ones upon a time you guys
think is like the highlight of my con
every year so let's get started with
these fabulous people I want to bring up
first the executive producers and once
upon a time let's bring out any pizzas
and at Horowitz
hi guys how are you
he's really beautiful and scruffy I love
it up next we have the fabulous Jared
Gilmore plays Henry news he's gotten so
big I can't stand him he's fighting hey
I think you're burned out then help out
any help
up next is the villainous we're all so
sweet
the wicked witch Davina Rebecca Mader
we have the beautiful and winsome Bell
Italy dorammed
we have the handsome and charming and
also villainous and times Josh Dallas
with a spring shopping baby knowing we
have the amazing woman who plays Regina
and the Evil Queen Jana bunny I love
that outfit love the Apple yes doll yes
up next is the beautiful and fierce in
the Swan way my Jim Morrison
and last but not least the roguishly
handsome hope so cute
hi guys we're doing it again feelin okay
so let's start with Emily let's get
happy and sunshiny let's go to Emily
Emily hi honey hi um Rumple has put
Belle through a lot of stuff through the
years um and she keeps believing um I
want to know what is the draw for Belle
with Rumple what is it about him that
makes her go I'm gonna keep believing no
matter what he does to me and my unborn
child right now gerald a baby's in peril
yeah good question I think that she and
Moshe I guess we all could see towards
the end last season for the first time
she's acknowledging and realizing that
part of that pool is him being good and
bad guy she likes that even though deep
down yes she sees the good in him she
sees a wonderful person a loving person
he can be but that darkness she likes
that side of that that definitely pulls
her in and why she's you know stuck by
him and hung around to a degree I think
she's struggling with that quite a bit
that's kind of cool okay she likes the
bad guy all right Lonnie no sunshine see
shamelessly right um Lana I call her
Lana she doesn't - yes we saw an amazing
arc for you this year there has been a
Regina was redeemed and then she lost
the great love of her life or soul mate
um and now she splits she split herself
into and she's become Regina and the
Evil Queen what my question is how how
complete is this is a split is Regina
fully good and the Evil Queen fully evil
or is there just still a mixture in
Regina because we like that little bit
of mischief in her Regina's still sassy
okay she's not gonna lose her sass um
that's an applause line if I've ever
heard an applause well
we like our Regina Santa question I
actually asked Adam and Eddie as well
because I thought is she just now this
peer or you know light being kind of I
guess you would say she's and they said
well no not really cuz she's still you
know sassy and that's Regina she's
sarcastic and that's what we love about
her um so she's not gonna lose that but
the Evil Queen is slightly different
than she used to be oh I I think I would
think that Adam and Eddie agree yeah she
is now without a conscience so she's
pure evil and a lot of fun
Regina is desperate to really you know
be this hero and be happy internally
like deep down inside and that's really
what she wants for herself she has this
beautiful family now and haha and if she
doesn't
Rebekah's like me I'm that family go
ahead and her sister sisters we have a
lot of fun we do yeah so it's it's going
to be an interesting journey this year
to see how the two versions of Regina
and well the Evil Queen and Regina sort
of coexist coexist yeah all right uh
Josh speaking of duality yeah yeah you
were huge
yeah it's just marvel at how cute he is
4-minute let's just take that moment you
drink it in
drink it in um you got to play two sides
of both to different people but you got
to be yourself and then also your evil
brother so what was that like for you
getting to show that other side of you
as an actor uh it was it was great you
know it was a chance for Charming to see
everything that he didn't want to be or
everything he didn't ever want to become
and you know he wanted to have a
relationship with his brother and he
always felt a connection with them and I
wish you know he wishes that he could
have got you know to know him but that
just wasn't the case but I you know he
his brother was a reminder to him
anything that he wanted to avoid and
stay away from and not become mm-hmm
yeah I'm sorry I got it was a charm
attack I just I forgot that I was in my
brain I had questions and it just went
out my head
Palin and Jen this is first a request
directly from the Twitter's as I like to
call them they'd like you somebody's
head needs to go on somebody's shoulder
and somebody needs to put an arm around
something there's some you know what I'm
talking about you guys you guys did
something adorable on your own that we
now want to recreate for this panel so I
don't know head on the shoulder and
hugger oh there was a picture I get the
picture okay this is my question for you
guys um at the end and your final scene
together there was a wedding dress um
there's a wedding dress where discuss
you didn't see it we saw all right I
think I know what this is uh where's
that it's in the shop window behind
isn't a shop window we saw is that it's
um on the set and it's it's always been
there yeah it wasn't specifically put
there it's just the dress that was in
the window but I don't think it's a
wedding dress I Emma's gonna go shopping
maybe yeah
go ahead get in there well I think we
can all agree if it was Emma's wedding
dress it would be red leather even know
what everyone's reading into weight
eating like this district right a lot in
fact a lot like that Oh what can we
infer okay no okay
Ben borrowed hey Jared yes first yes
first of all you've grown and it makes
me very uncomfortable cuz you're now
taller than me that's the first second
Henri kind of spread his wings this year
he rebelled a bit in my opinion okay I
was a little rebellion in him um what in
your mind has he learned this year about
the importance his importance in his
family and where he stands does he feel
that he's a vital part of it where does
he fit in I think now that Henry is the
author he's gained that thing that I am
a hero now and my way of helping people
is by being able to give them their
stories and help them figure things out
and I think Henry has found his place
and he believes that now he is a part of
the heroes and I think he likes it he
loves it thank you
this voice is deep now - it's all very
uncomfortable for me I don't know
Rebecca hi how you doing how're you hey
girl Rebecca and I are gonna do a sitcom
after both of our shows are over we
decided on the name of the show well
Rebecca you're something Selina has had
quite an arc this year what in your
opinion has changed her more becoming a
mom reconciling with her sister or being
loved and loved being Hades of those
three which is the one that is the
biggest thing that made her go I'm
turning a corner call my pickle know
them yeah yeah all of them I mean I
think it's a it's a plethora it's a
cacophony if you will of everything I
mean it's a lot happened all at once in
terms of like breaking downs Elena's
heart you know you know I think the
reason she got pregnant was for horrible
reasons but then it ended up really
changing her and she didn't I don't
think she really expected or understood
that having a baby meant having
unconditional love and I think that
melted her heart little bit it was also
hard for her to you know accept and
believe that a man could actually love
her because she had such a rubbish life
and then all of a sudden her sister gave
her her trust when she really quite
frankly didn't deserve it so there's
like these three people that loved her
even though
she didn't really feel like she was
worth it and I think that's changed in a
really powerful fundamental way and it's
been really fun to play and Hades is
gone I had to save Regina as you do and
I'm carrying the baby and I'm really
enjoying you know this season so far I
can't wait to see what's going to happen
Adam and Eddie
I noticed that Zeus he stepped in and he
changed um cooks fate KITT that's not
the question it's not the question yet
can xue somehow interfere in all eternal
matters well I feel like that was a
one-time-only Zeus interference based
Thank You soos hey y'all Jin's like
thank Zeus wait he could again you could
have given me back my hand yes sir yeah
I got magic back his hand I keep
wondering that you haven't earned it
back homina homina oh I really want two
hands
I like the hug I mean he loved that hook
that's my name my about that this is for
a genin Lana Emma Regina's connection is
one of my favorite parts of the show you
guys have spent a lot of time helping
each other loving each other and
encouraging each other towards accepting
every part of yourselves how would they
relate how will their relationship
evolve now that Regina possibly has no
ill will towards Emma and the Evil Queen
has nothing but ill-will towards
everybody gosh that's I had to write
that one down because I feel that in my
soul that's a very important question
right these women have grown so much
over the years and they become best
friends yeah and
it's such an admirable relationship and
I'm curious to see I know Regina and mr
are gonna well I don't know anything
actually do I Adam Eddie do we know
anything we know plenty well no honey
but we don't know what's gonna I have
only seen the first year we absolutely
seen yeah but um I know we're working
together and I think emma has really
helped Regina get to this new place in
her life where she's you know she's been
constant battle with this darkness and
emma has saved her many times and has
been a great vice versa and vice versa
um and I see them continuing down that
path now the evil queen is just another
entity itself I have no idea how she's
going to respond or react I think it's
gonna be complicated for Emma to
navigate because she wants to believe in
Regina and she wants to believe that
good can win but then she also knows she
needs to protect everyone she loves
right including you know everyone in her
family and that includes Regina you know
so it's like how do you separate the two
mentally and figure out where to draw
the line and how do you do that in a way
where you're not betraying the trust
that you've developed with this friend
for so long so I think it's going to be
complicated like it always is mm mm mm
mm but fun and an awesome journey okay
hey Colin and Josh we love your bromance
we also have our Alma I love our Bruma
do we have any more serious yeah do we
have some more fun times coming with the
two you guys I saw Road Trip something
Eddie Adam I would there's going to be
some fun times to be had it just depends
what your interpretation of funny yeah
no but we do we do get to see a hook and
charming together in a in a fun think
fun are yeah yeah so is he still the
hook we know and love is there a change
with him since he's come back from the
day I think he's I think he's still
there
pretty much the same hook I mean he he's
sort of trying to
you know now that they know that it's
sort of true love with Emma and hook
it's sort of sorry and well they're
they're trying to figure out how to
navigate being together in that sort of
world now and yeah so at the minute is
the same hook but who knows I think we
might find out a few things about his
past
oh we mean oh I can't tell you
everything today yeah but no there is
there's a little bit of more of hooks
past that we delve into and hopefully
some surprising secrets that have been
harbored hmm Oh Papa hook they want
power back or that's scoundrel really
you